welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we
are live iron love podcast lords of
gaming.net laura cognito here and who is
this fine gentleman that we have in the
round today
hi i'm pavel i'm from association games
and i'm developer on the female
very very popular these days for this
amazing title demio one of my favorite
games actually of last year came out for
the metaphase vr and it is also on pc so
problem tell us about the reception of
vimeo since you've come out now on pc
how is the game being received crossplay
and the whole day
so we are getting really nice feedback
about the pc version
people like really enjoying the gameplay
and the game didn't lose its magic in
the 2d version because that's what we're
afraid of
but the vr and the pc are both awesome
and people love it it is so cool because
for for turn-based fans that people
don't realize you know you have the
turn-based aspect then you have this
cool dungeons and dragons aspect you
have the different classes and now a
whole subset of people are now getting
to play this game so the first thing i
was going to ask you is since it's been
released we know you got more content on
the roadmap coming is there anything you
can tell us about potential modes and
potential features that people want more
demio they're excited
yeah i know i would love to tell you
more about what's going on what i can't
they keep with the clones the vessel
as you saw in the trailers we are coming
two new adventures in this year
one around summer and one at the end of
the year cool cool we love adventures
roots of evil is probably one of our
favorites that i think we love the boss
battles are absolutely excellent great
contact now the other question i had is
in reference to the classes i know me
and lord atticus have done some
discussion about our good friend the
mage the magician
what do you think in the future there's
also potential balance patches or
anything that could happen as far as
abilities or cars maybe in the future
maybe certain cars can be added to
different armed characters
yeah so we
we want to add as many cards as we want
but
we
we will introduce new heroes
and those heroes will be having cards
they're the current game at point
adventures they will be as they were we
won't be expanding the current fuel
gotcha okay so those people
now the other thing is what have you
been now that the pc release has been
out
what are some of the feedback that you
see from players like getting into this
whole new ecosystem of details you see
we got this great group going on right
here but like what do you feel has been
some of the reception from people on pc
so
that's a good question
yeah so
i think people like
for sound this is like the tiny new game
they never played the vr it's like we
we encountered a new public
which never like never heard about the
vr and they can start with the pc
version and that's the way we are like
also bringing people to the vr yeah yes
yes yes and the cross play works really
really awesome and it's really nice to
see like the vr play is the dungeon
crawling in the 2d screen yes and you
keep wondering what's what this was
about yeah and then you figure out
there's also vr version right and that's
why we want to bring the vr because
resolution games is about the vr
absolutely it's so impressive to see
resolution games what you guys have been
doing to grow everything's spectacular
the other thing you dropped was the
hangout and i thought that was a really
cool social feature because it's like
you get everybody in this room and you
literally have the pieces of the game
you can take the adventures place it in
the vr space and start a session you
know is there um just basically i guess
what was your thought process behind it
why did you feel the need i i love it
well why did you feel the need to even
extend that level of connection yeah so
we are in this kind of place where
people can hang out and like talk before
between games or like count other
players because
for now you could only like go to
discord and find other people to play
with now you can just go to the hangout
yeah and you can talk with people and
yeah they want to play yeah let's try
that's the easiest way to find people to
play with if you don't have like four
players yes yeah it is so cool and i
absolutely love it it's it's a cool song
whoa designed the demo gauntlet that man
deserves a rage he deserves an absolute
right that is amazing you got what you
got you got darts you got a whole thing
going on and it's really cool so again
really want to celebrate you guys we're
so excited to see the future of demio
yeah for sure it's an absolutely
addicting game one of my favorites and
i'm just excited to see more people get
to play i know we i know future plans
are close to best
but the console guys would love to play
this game i'm just saying i mean there's
a lot of guys with xbox and playstation
love to play it and they get excited
when they see the pc version
we can't promise anything but yeah we
want dino everywhere right that's good
we like that yeah we like that you want
dvr
so look there you have it dino pc
edition is out right now available on
steam beyond metaquest all the vr
services crossplay enabled adventures
coming yeah pvp coming yeah that's okay
he's not gonna say nothing about any
classes
but hey old buffs but if the future is
bright gmail gave me a higher level of
podcast love to gaming an absolute
pleasure probably always great
salute to resolution games of the team
amazing guys
[Music]